foreign
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
yeah
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
loud
and do not give a [__]
this is the Tony Michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty you [__]
eating [__] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the Tony Michaels podcast
and this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony [__] em
[Music]
thank you
so she's ready to indict it's almost
September 1st
why do you why do you think that they're
getting testimony from Hunter Biden's
ex-business partner Devin whatever the
hell his name is oh man here's what
they're gonna say this afternoon and
Vonnie Willis is about to indict Donald
Trump in Georgia
and she'd said it over the weekend to a
local news station and she's ready she's
got the case
I told the American people and the
people of Fulton County that I was going
to make my move by September
first what's July
so we're getting close we're getting so
close
we're almost there and that is why this
morning
they're going to
hell
yeah every time there's Hunter by news
that's what they're gonna say over the
weekend you know on Friday Donald Trump
uh there was a super seeding indictment
I told you to remember the word
superseding indictment that these would
be great grand words that you must know
because it appears that there's going to
be another one uh I guess there was
several employees that are going to be
indicted on co-conspirators of
destroying evidence
I guess
I I guess he bleached he bleached the
cameras he put bleach on him or
something he bleached watched them or
something right
uh Greg Gutfeld really got some [__]
over the weekend Greg Gutfeld of Fox
News like oh what the what the hell's
the big deal destroying evidence
oh my God this is the same these are the
same people
that were saying lock her up because
Hillary Clinton had a few emails on her
server
that may or may not have classified
markings it was unclear really if they
were supposed to be marked classified a
few a couple losing their [__] minds
remember this
we were gonna lock her up we were gonna
disembowel her and put her in gitmo or
some I don't remember exactly what the
thing we were supposed to do they never
did it they they voted they voted Donald
Trump in to lock her up and he didn't
it's because he's a weak feeble piece of
[__]
but funny Willis you talk about women
coming after him God damn
I'm gonna show you that I'm going to
show you the interview where she's like
yeah I promise the American people and
Fulton County September 1st and I'm
gonna make my move
work almost August tomorrow's August
uh I what do you think do you think do
you think phony Willis moves on him
and grabs him by the indictments before
Jack Smith does for January 6th what do
you think what do you think what's your
guess what's your take
uh you know what the problem is none of
this [__] matters
he's still gonna be their nominee
Ron DeSantis is absolutely [__]
drowning in weirdness have you noticed
that
this guy I don't even know if this guy's
gonna make it to to the Georgia
indictments uh DeSantis
he's a he's a [__] weirdo man
I I told Ron I tried to tell him he
wouldn't listen to me I told him on the
show I continued to say hey man
listen
you gotta get out there and get out
front and you really gotta punch on this
guy you really gotta punch on him and he
wouldn't do it he wouldn't get in the
race he should have just bowed out he
should have just said I'm not going to
be Governor anymore I'm gonna go all in
for president
he obviously does not want to be
president that bad he hates he hates his
life on the campaign Trail have you
noticed that
have you noticed this this is this is a
guy this is a guy who hates what he's
doing
he can't even order a beer without it
being weird
you can't he's trying to drink a beer it
looks awkward I don't know he looks like
he's holding a dildo or something Have
you seen this
have you seen this is weird stuff
weird stuff
and I don't I don't know if he's
drinking because he's trying to appear
normal
but it looks like he's not normal
so stop holding beers and the other
thing too is it was a Cooler's light and
everyone who's anyone knows if you're a
real man you don't drink coolers light
that's a woke ass beer Ron don't you
know then come on man
this isn't difficult stuff
I could give you this advice how much
are you paying your team to come up with
this [__]
you've spent like 20 million dollars
and Vivek Rama Swami is ahead of you in
in your fake ass rig pulls
what the [__]
speaking of of candidates in the
Republican primary Donald Trump says
this morning that he's not going to
debate him oh what a surprise what a
surprise Donald Trump isn't gonna debate
him I love how everyone on Twitter
everyone on Twitter is like I predicted
this
I predicted this that's a that's what
they say
listen uh you know you can predict all
you want and say two weeks ago you said
this
I've been saying since the end of
December that Trump was going to be
their nominee that there was no way
DeSantis was ever going to have a chance
in hell is what I was saying
I don't know if you remember we can go
back and roll the tape if we need to but
these people on the on Twitter like I
predicted this weeks ago weeks
weeks well you're way behind the [__]
times friend
I've been saying that Donald Trump was
going to be the nominee since the end of
December
beginning of January I said it over and
over he's gonna be the nominee and these
indictments are only going to propel him
he had superseding indictments and the
people at his rally the few the tens of
people at his rally
this weekend the Nazi rally that it had
where was it Pennsylvania is that where
this was
I don't know does it matter
the trumpies the moglodytes are posting
online rallies with crowds as far as the
eye can see outside this one was inside
it was inside
hmm whoosh
ah but I got some tape for you from the
trader TV news networks oh my God they
never fail why do they stand outside
these rallies and put microphones in
front of his supporters faces
I I have no idea I couldn't tell you why
this distance
what why would you do that you wouldn't
do that if you want him to win
you would you would make sure to really
really really really check these people
to make sure they're not gonna say crazy
ass [__] into a microphone one guy says
kill them all kill all of them
what the what in the Nazi hell is this
look folks he's gonna be their nominee
there's no one not now no one's gonna
stop him the reason why Donald Trump
won't go on stage to debate these idiots
is because he's terrified of Chris
Christie
that's right if Chris Christie wasn't on
stage he would go try to [__] torch
all of them but he knows he knows Chris
Christie is not gonna stand there and
take his [__]
which Chris Christie shouldn't honestly
that's the one reason why Chris
Christie's in the race is to show people
that he's the tough guy for 2028.
that's why he's in the race
because they know they're going to need
a tough guy to beat Gavin Newsom in 2028
that's their thought that's their
thought process
and they're gonna have to move on past
Trump dude's gonna be in [__] jail
I don't know if you noticed this I don't
know if you noticed this
dude dude Steph I look I I've been
trying to figure out how they're going
to incarcerate this fat [__] slob
once he goes to trial and he's convicted
It's Gonna Take Years though
we're going to continue this garbage for
years because there is a two-tier
justice system in this country and the
rich white [__] like him get to take
advantage of it and they get to stay out
on [__] appeal like Steve Bannon
these other [__] these other pieces
of trash
when when average people like reality
winner with one document one document
get locked up immediately and they don't
let them loose until they absolutely
have to there is two tears of Justice in
this [__] country
and the reason why they're pissed off
about Donald Trump is the second tier
isn't fully protecting him that
privileged ass white rich man tear isn't
protecting him the way they wanted to
that's why they're [__] mad
but it's coming for him it's coming for
him I don't know
if you understand how superseding
indictments work well let me let me give
you let me give you some idea I'm not a
[__] attorney you guys know this I'm
gonna turn I just have a little bit of
experience in this area
listen
when you're federally indicted it is a
serious [__] matter especially when
there's dozens dozens of felony counts
charged against you
then when they rope in other low-level
conspirators
into a superseding indictment they're
trying to get them
to flip
you understand
that's what they're trying to do is to
get them to flip
and they will they will get them to flip
that's why Donald Trump is paying for
there's a his attorneys through his
supporters money through Super PAC
literally is grifting his supporters to
pay for his co-conspirators attorneys so
they won't turn on him
that's the [__] scheme that we're in
right now that's why Grandpa is
absolutely losing his mind on true
social I'm not going to read every
single [__] one from the weekend
Jesus Christ we would have to be on here
for four hours to read every single one
of his deranged little rants on fraud
social this weekend he's losing his
[__] mind
and the reason why is because he's a
caged animal
and a lunatic
not only that his entire Step at
Mar-A-Lago seems to be turning on him at
least that's the
that's the threat
I don't know if you noticed but in some
of these statements of these indictments
one of the staff that is indicted now is
a co-conspirator there's an unnamed
Trump employee
in those indictments meaning that
unnamed Trump employee is now evidence
of the state
you get that right these people are
already turning on his ass and he knows
it
why do you think he's paying for the
attorneys and the people who are getting
indicted
with his own supporters money
because he's the victim oh oh they're
not indicting me they're indicting you
no they're certainly indicting you
[__]
oh man you know what you know what you
know what I think we should do I think
this is a fair I just had this thought
Jesus Christ this is a great great great
idea just hear me out on this just
follow me on this okay this is not how
it works this isn't how it's gonna be
but this is this would be a great
fantastic
compromise if you will
you know how
he's like they're not
they're not indicting me they're
indicting you well when he's convicted
wouldn't it be great wouldn't it be
great if all his supporters could go
serve his prison sentence for him how
fantastic would that be you know what I
actually think I would comfort make that
compromise keep him out if all every
single [__] one of them has to go
serve the sentence for him when that oh
my God
[__] [__] at least we would get some
silence at least we should have some
sanity for a while I mean you know he
would still be yelling and screaming
and spouting out conspiracy theories but
at least if all his supporters went and
served jail time
for him since you know they're being
indicted he's being indicted for them
they might as well serve the sentence
right maybe just maybe we could have a
couple years of Silence in this country
he says [__] Christ
these people are nut bags they're nut
bags they're [__] nuttier than
squirrel turds I'm gonna show you some
clips from this weekend from his rally
and they are getting dumber and dumber
and dumber and dumber
it's it's the absolute epitome of
delusion
and derangement they're they they're out
in left field they're gone
all foam no beer all foam no beer
I don't care if it's Bud Light or not
whoo I'm gonna show you some of these
people and this and again this is only
evidence why
he's going to win you're not
understanding oh oh by the way Ron
DeSantis can't attract flies to [__]
anymore
yeah Ron DeSantis can't even get tens of
people to show up at his little events
he's really banking on Iowa and he's not
playing very well there he's [__] Ron
DeSantis is screwed do you remember
Scott Walker you probably don't
you probably don't remember Scott Walker
I've talked about Scott Walker several
times on the show do you remember him do
you remember who I'm talking about Scott
Walker used to be the the governor the
governor of Wisconsin
right Paul Ryan's home state oh he's
good buddies with Paul Ryan and reince
priebus do you remember reince priebus
reince priebus was the head of the RNC
in 2016. he became Donald Trump's first
Chief of Staff that [__] piled
garbage
all right priebus and Paul Ryan they
were best buds with Scott Walker the
governor of Wisconsin they try to recall
Scott Scott Walker in Wisconsin
they weren't successful in their recall
which only elevated his status amongst
the idiots in the Republican party they
thought this guy's gonna be the
president he's gonna be the president
that that bashes up Medicare and Social
Security that's what they were excited
about they really loved Scott Walker
because he was a nice friendly white
face
I was clean cut had the haircut had the
look had the all Shucks Midwestern
attitude he was a governor he was primed
to smash up Social Security and Medicare
this was their guy this was this was
Paul Ryan's guy that was going to end
Medicare and Social Security entitlement
programs our safety net in this country
he was really going to make the rich
richer and the poor poor they loved
Scott Walker they loved him
and then he went to Iowa
any [__] drowned
he drowned he didn't have a [__] shot
didn't he make it to the straw poll I
don't think maybe he made it to the
struggle I don't remember
but he didn't last a single minute
because he he drowned in Iowa
the same thing that Ron DeSantis is
doing
Rhonda Santos looks miserable just like
Scott Walker did weird almost almost
robotic
because he's trying to pretend he's from
Iowa and he's not just like
Scott Walker tried to pretend he was
from Iowa and he wasn't which he's from
Wisconsin which is kind of like Iowa 2.0
anybody out there from Wisconsin I'm not
trying to offend
I know how it goes
oh boy
Rhonda santis Ronnie stop man just quit
it's not even worth it at this point
just stop man just back Trump
just get on the fascist movement go
finish out your little your little
fascist
your little fascist term down in Florida
destroy Florida and go do that how about
that I mean you're destroying it we're
not even there
so go go go participate in the
destroying of Florida
uh so that
oh
man what what what a timeline that we're
in
this week could serve us up even more
indictments in more than one District
more than one more than one jurisdiction
that looks like finally Willis is going
to make her move uh in August it looks
like probably probably this week and
we're going to start to see movement
they have barriers outside in Fulton
County
to fend off any kind of violent
moglodytes that want to storm the gourd
house to stop the indictment which
listen if you're if if you're not this
this is the problem
is they already arrested thousands of
these people who tried to make him
Dictator by using violence
okay
some of them are still in prison some of
them lost their entire lives and their
livelihoods which good on them
but you said you think you think there's
going to be a violent uprising
I mean when you see these [__]
brainless idiots that I'm gonna show you
from this Trump rally just tell me if
you think you're they're gonna go storm
the courthouse
in Fulton County Georgia to stop Donald
Trump from being indicted give me a
[__] break they didn't do it in New
York they didn't do it in South Florida
they're not going to do it in [__] DC
and they're definitely not going to do
it in Fulton County the only risk there
is is some kind of [__] lunatic
who's been deluded by Fox News oan and
Newsmax and Grandpa Poopypants himself
and goes and commits acts of violence
alone that's the biggest risk that we
have not that they're gonna try to do
this as a group of people Jesus Christ
these people can't even work themselves
out of a wet paper sack anymore that's
how dumb they are again it's getting
Dumber as we go along
just imagine when we get to the general
election next year when he's holding
rallies and there's only [__] 100
people showing up and it's the most
ridiculous hundred people that you'll
find anywhere in the country yeah that's
right I said it that's what's gonna
happen
listen when he gets the nomination
they're all gonna be just just be like
oh [__] this is great
but they're not gonna have a choice you
know that right they're not gonna have a
choice but to give it to them because of
delegates
this is how this works
and when you when you're watching the
mainstream media and you're hearing this
nonsense about someone coming up in the
polls and that oh man we're so far off
we are not that far off
listen he's baked the cake folks
they're excited about voting for him
even if he's a criminal actually
honestly that's the [__] feature they
like that part they like that he's a
[__] crooked piece of [__] they love
that he's a hateful [__] they
hate that he they love that he's a hate
Monger they love it they love it they
love being the worst version of
themselves and there's no one that
displays that in human form than Donald
Trump himself that's what's gonna happen
[__] doubt me
as Donald Trump sends a message this
morning on fraud social saying I'm not
gonna go to debate but I might choose
one of them I might choose one of them
as my vice president Vivek
I've been saying it all along he's a
[__] plant
he's a plant they're gonna rig up all
kinds of poles to make Vivek ramashami
the number two and what's gonna happen
before the primary start is Vivek is
going to join Trump probably more than
likely
that's right that's right
they're building up a crypto Bro Army
with vivec to back Trump online that's
what they're doing
and he's going to choose him he's gonna
flip side oh it's a Unity ticket that's
what the [__] they're gonna say it's a
Unity ticket and they're gonna Donald
Trump is gonna sweep the [__]
delegates in every goddamn primary every
one of them including California
and if you don't see it then you're not
paying attention
I've been paying attention for a long
time how Colts work and this is how they
work and this is what's gonna happen
so that so to act like you're on social
media and you called that he wasn't
gonna [__] debate
I mean you can get mad at me for you
know I'm not pointing any specific
fingers but you can go look at it just
go just get go look at the
you'll see who I'm talking about there's
a bunch of them and I'm not saying I
don't like these people but man I've
been predicting this [__] for a long
time
acting like it was them who called this
[__] out of here with that nonsense
I've been calling this for a long time
and I continue will continue to call it
and I'll continue to say exactly what is
going to happen Donald Trump will sweep
delegates in Iowa New Hampshire
he's going to sweep the delegates it's
going to absolutely destroy the field
I don't know exactly when he'll do his
Unity ticket but my guess is is the only
person he'll debate is vivec
that's it because Vivek is a plant he's
there for Trump the same way no labels
is for Trump we know that
we're not dumb
it's ridiculous of course it's for Trump
he can't win he cannot win a general
election he can't
it's just the cold hard facts
there's no there's not enough support
for him in the country that really is
the big lie
the big lie is that this country likes
him we do not
we do not want him we want him to go the
[__] away but his cult members will not
allow it
and Republicans only vote based on
Association
that's it an affiliation that's it
affiliation and Association and he's
going to be the nominee
and they're gonna vote for him all the
way up and down the board even the
people who are saying he needs to go to
prison I mean I'll vote for him he's the
Republican but God damn he's a crook
Bill Barr included
yes Bill Barr will vote for Donald Trump
yeah he will
Chris Christie
I bet he votes for Donald Trump don't
[__] don't put it past him I wouldn't
put it past Chris Christie to support
Donald Trump even after all he said
what what do you want from me Chris
Christie's a republican isn't he isn't
he
you think he won't maybe he won't
maybe he won't
I mean I think Chris Christie's running
for 2028 if you want to know the honest
truth but that's how it goes that's how
it'll be
grab him by the indictments funny Willis
boy what a Newsweek it is going to be I
am excited to have you here on the Tony
Michaels podcast on this Monday July
31st thanks for hanging around for the
long weekend I know some people are like
go take a day off and some people like
God damn it Tony
why were you gone on Friday look man
look a dude's gotta take a day off every
once in a while right it's summertime
I I promise that it wasn't intended to
be that way
we just had it on the schedule and we
couldn't cover it
so I apologize for Friday
but I had fun I had great I get a great
three day weekend it was great time off
I'm excited to be here with you
we did a great planning meeting
yesterday on patreon a lot of you were
there for the planning meeting on
patreon we got this thing going the
round table of democracy over there on
patreon I don't know we're gonna make
all the videos that we produce over
there on the round table of democracy
all those Workshops the giving you the
tools on how to engage in your democracy
we're going to make all that available
for you to see
so don't don't worry if you're not a
member of patreon don't worry you're
gonna get to see the workshops but if
you want to participate in the workshops
if you want to participate in the
planning meetings for the workshops we
had a lot of great ideas last night from
the audience there on patreon about what
kind of workshops what kind of tools
they want
what kind of topics they want to hear
about what kind of Educational Tools
they want us to find to provide to you
guys because that's really the thing I
tell you all the time engage in your
democracy engage in your democracy use
your strategic outrage to engage in your
democracy
and I was missing one little component I
think
one little component was to give you the
tools you need to engage in your
democracy they're out there they exist
we don't even have to create a lot of
these tools we just have to find them
and show you how to use them and that's
what these Roundtable democracy
workshops are about
and we we did fivecalls.org it is on the
YouTube channel right now if you go to
playlist
and you go to Round Table of democracy
you will find that video and you will
find our planning meeting from last
night on patreon so just go to the
YouTube channel click subscribe right
now on the YouTube channel it's
absolutely free you can go to the
playlist tab it's at the very top the
playlist tabs at the top
you just hit playlist and there's the
round table of democracy playlist
and that playlist will give you all the
Roundtable democracies that we will do
there's only two of them in there right
now
but we will be doing so many more we
plan on having Nick O'Neill the founder
of
fivecalls.org he's going to come join us
and do a do a workshop we want uh Jess
Piper has committed I think I think uh
not this week but next week she's going
to come and do a workshop on patreon
you'll get to see it if you're not a
member of patreon don't worry you're
gonna get the CDs now if you want to
come ask Jess questions and you want to
talk to her in the chat live come on to
patreon just go to patreon.com the Tony
Michaels you can find your way there
but we're going to do one on education
and how to engage with with your elected
officials on education just Piper is
going to do a workshop on how to do that
next week I'm super excited about that
one we're going to try to do workshops
on email campaigns texting campaigns how
do I write a letter how do I write a
postcard oh I want to do canvassing
where do I find a campaign that I help
and volunteer there's going to be so
many workshops that we're going to do
over over the course of the next year so
make sure make sure to go to patreon.com
if you want to participate in those
workshops but even if you just want to
watch the workshops for free you can do
it right here on YouTube so don't forget
to subscribe right here on YouTube at
the Tony Michaels podcast go to the
playlist tab you will find the round
table of democracy playlist right there
and if you want to watch this show every
day and you want to hit the like button
I'm trying to get at YouTube hit the
like button or if you don't like the
show
[__] you but at least hit the dislike
button if you don't like it
I'm not that great at YouTube uh you can
also watch it on Facebook at the Tony
Michaels if you still have books of face
go follow us on Facebook at the Tony
Michaels you can also watch us on Twitch
twitch.tv slash the Tony Michaels
remember we we're down with our
subscribers on the Prime account thing
again so if you have a Prime account
link to the Twitch account you gotta go
in and resubscribe
go in there resubscribe all the
directions are at the Tony michaels.com
that's the attorney michaels.com don't
forget to go to the Tony michaels.com
how do you link because here's the thing
if you have an Amazon Prime account and
you link it to the Twitch account you
can give us that one free subscription
you get with your Prime account
and we get a couple bucks of Amazon's
money every month it doesn't cost you a
single extra dime if you're a Prime
member
you just gotta go in and resubscribe we
just had a DJ Sam re-subscribe for the
fourth month just a few minutes ago
um and we had a few others re-subscribe
for the fourth month in a row just a few
minutes ago so go in if you've got a
Amazon Prime account tie it to your
Twitch account give us that one free
subscription you get with your Amazon
Prime account to the Tony Michaels
podcast all the directions are on the
Tony michaels.com that's the Tony
michaels.com also download every single
episode of the Tony Michaels podcast on
Apple Spotify and Google its free 99 it
doesn't cost you a single nickel to
download the audio version and you
should it helps us out getting us in the
rankings pushing our show out to
hundreds and thousands of more people
every single week don't go anywhere
I'm gonna show you these videos of this
crazy Nazi rally over the weekend
we'll be right back right after this
what the [__] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the Tony Michaels
podcast
[Music]
fellow Patriots what would you do if
there was a trump supporter right in
front of you crying in pain because they
have to live under communist tyranny we
know what you would do you'd reach out
and give that true American a hand now
here's your chance for only fifty
dollars a day you can help us help those
true Americans recover from Biden's
socialist reign of terror these are
those Trump supporters and this is that
moment send your donation via venmo to
the real president Donald J Trump it's
only fifty dollars a day recurring and
it means you'll get these Trump
supporters the critical help they so
desperately need to survive under this
false regime please donate now because
those Trump supporters you just saw
can't wait another moment where
back to the Tony Michaels podcast
[Music]
welcome back to the show
it's Monday July 31st
[Music]
Bonnie Willis is getting her indictments
ready
Donald
Jessica
Trump and then his middle name now what
J stands for Jessica
maybe not
I think it's Jessica though
I want to thank all of you for for
sticking with us you guys came back I
know Friday
you didn't get your cathartic release
for the Tony Michaels it was only one
day again
[__] needs a day off every once
in a while just like Joe Biden needs to
take a beach day did you see this [__]
oh my God they were freaking the [__]
out they were freaking out because Joe
Biden had his shirt off at the beach
what the f are you [__] Jesus Christ
are you kidding me oh my God the media
sucks so bad that you are so horrible
and I'm not just talking about the right
wing
ridiculous
Nazi lunatics out there I'm also talking
about the mainstream eater they're
ridiculous that that it that it's a
story that Joe Biden takes his shirt off
at the Beach come on
what's next Joe Biden showers naked can
you believe it what the [__] are you
people talking about yeah he took his
shirt off at the beach
oh my God
he swam in the ocean
ah damn what
how are these stories the reason why is
because Joe Biden isn't out there
committing [__] crime and getting
indicted on hundreds of felony counts
because he's a constant criminal and and
so now we gotta talk about how he had
his shirt off at the beach he's at the
beach what the [__] what the [__] do you
think a dude's gonna do with that most
dudes take their shirt off at the beach
God damn they're sitting under an
umbrella reading books you [__]
idiots
get over it
get the [__] over this is so dumb
the president of the United States went
on a weekend to the beach to relax and
read and spend time with his wife
like a married couple would do every
once in a while is take a few hours to
go
relax with each other enjoy each other's
company the [__] are you people
blathering about
the former guy
has over 70 felonies
he's probably gonna have over a hundred
in the next month felonies
he's indicted in two jurisdictions right
now by the by the by the beginning of
September probably four jurisdictions
what the [__] are you people talking
about
can you imagine can you even imagine if
Donald Trump actually went to the beach
just went to the beach and a pair of
swimming trunks
are you kidding me
and then he took his shirt off that
[__] fat slob wouldn't be caught dead
with his shirt off that's how [__]
nasty he is he knows how nasty he is
come on man
I'm not trying to body shame anybody but
I am I I am I am body shaming Donald
Trump
come on [__] out of here with this
nonsense don't we have better [__] to do
let me show you I'm gonna show you this
is dumb I know it feels stupid but
I don't I don't even talk about Joe
Biden on the show this much because of
this stupid kind of [__]
I don't I don't because of this stupid
[__] because it's it's so ridiculous and
it's so it's ridiculous it's absolutely
ridiculous here's here's Joe Biden and
his wife relaxing on the beach reading
you can see they're underneath an
umbrella I'll play the clip here it
appears from this camera angle that
they're the only one on the beach right
well this is the president of the United
States that is sitting on the beach with
his wife reading obviously reading
probably working is probably what Joe
Biden's doing he's probably working
if you want to know the truth
he's probably not even relaxing that
much
right
and you can see people walking along the
beach here and they're walking pretty
far away from Joe Biden here's the thing
all the mongoloidites on the internet
this weekend are like oh why isn't
everyone running up to him if you see
here it's because the Secret Service is
surrounding him he's the president look
he that look how many people are on the
beach look how many Secret Service
people are standing around making sure
no one goes up to the president because
they're relaxing
the [__] what the hell are you talking
about
and of course in this picture he didn't
have a shirt off right
they're just relaxing underneath an
umbrella enjoying the ocean enjoying the
view enjoying the sound the wind the
warm the warm air Jesus [__] who the
[__] doesn't know why you go to the
beach
this is so ridiculous
this is what the [__] media this is
what the media comes up with
I don't I don't know what else to tell
you
it's ridiculous but this is what they do
well that's all I'm gonna show you then
I mean I can probably show you some of
the outrage oh my god oh my God
the president United
's on the beach with
love what
it's all to distract from this
touch has this this morning Trump
rejected again
he's rejected in court hmm seems like a
pattern seems like Tom Fenton's little
legal advice isn't working for trumpy
says Fulton and and by the way Tom Finn
is not a lawyer but he still gives legal
advice to Donald Trump Donald Trump
takes it
um here is the Fulton County Superior
Court Judge Robert Bernie just dismissed
Donald Trump's attempt to disqualify
Bonnie Willis preventing her from using
evidence derived from this from the
special purpose grand jury and block
expected indictments out of Fulton
County sorry [__] denied [__] you
this is why they have to spread
and talk about
Joe Biden with his shirt off on the
beach it's because of this
this is why
he's going to be indicted again
in Fulton County now let me show you the
the actual clip of fawny Willis saying
hey uh yeah um I'm going to indict him
oh by the way it's it's gonna be
tomorrow
I'm not tomorrow but you know what I
mean watch
this is that on News 10
uh a local station there in Georgia and
they interviewed uh Fami Willis listen
first warming up made a commitment to
the American people but most importantly
the citizens of Fulton County that um we
were going to be making some big uh
decisions regarding the election
investigation and that I would do that
before September the 1st of 2023 and I'm
going to hold through that commitment
boom she's gonna hold true to that
commitment but this last statement here
is one that I want you to hear listen to
this so she's gonna within the next
month with I I I'm guessing um the month
of August
within the first week or two so we're in
the first week of August now so this
week or next week we're going to see
these indictments of Donald Trump in
Georgia but listen to the part this is
the most important part this is the
piece of evidence that everyone needs
the American people this is what Bonnie
Willis is trying to say out loud that
hey
uh well I'll let her see it the work is
accomplished I mean we've been working
for two and a half years
first
so she says the work is accomplished
we've been working for two and a half
years and we're ready to go meaning
she's done she's ready to indict
they're just trying to plan make sure no
no shit's gonna get out of [__]
control
I think is what she's doing but you know
we'll see
we'll see when they drop
I think maybe there's some waiting on
Jack Smith too maybe
what do you think I think Bonnie Willis
is going to indict him before Jack Smith
on January 6th
on the election fraud
and election tampering
racketeering
that's what she's going to do
and she's going to do it before Jack
Smith does I believe
um so there's there's your
your lead story of Bonnie Willis making
her move on Donald Trump because not
only is fonnie Willis making her move on
Donald Trump
Donald Trump is being rejected in court
again again and and also
the house oversight committee I can't
help but distract from the Trump
indictments and the Trump losses in
court with Hunter button Hunter buttons
dick
look don't look over there Trump and
diamonds look over here at Hunter
Martin's [__] I mean they're they're
[__] ridiculous
we know that the hunter Biden uh plea
deal kind of fell apart right they want
to make bones about that which honestly
if I was Hunter Biden I would not take
the deal
the way that they were going to take the
deal but this morning
Hunter Biden's ex-business partner from
five years ago
this guy listen
Devin Archer
was convicted almost five years ago and
the Department of Justice let his white
rich ass
stay out of prison while he worked on
his appeal
he has went through all his Appeals
all of them he cannot appeal anymore he
has to serve this prison sentence
so the Department of Justice has tried
to get Devin Archer and his attorneys to
agree to a time when he's going to
surrender because his appeals are over
the house oversight committee knew this
they know this [__] this isn't [__]
news
this is actual [__] that you can look up
so they're gonna have Devin Archer come
in today in a closed door interview and
they're doing it closed door and the
reason why is because it's going to be
embarrassing for them
they do not want to do this out in the
open because it will absolutely
embarrass them
so what they're going to do is do it
behind closed doors they're not going to
release the transcript they're going to
say [__] like I guaran goddamn to you
just just [__] wait just [__] wait
till tonight on Fox News you have Jim
Comer Matt Gantz Jim Jordan me like oh
my God you should hear some of the
information we we can't even release the
transcript it it it's so sensitive
that's what they're gonna say
they're gonna say that [__] they're
gonna say Lord I can't we can't we can't
release the transcript of the interview
it's so sensitive there's so many crimes
that it appears that Hunter Baden
[__] out of here
it's nonsense
listen when they say oh my God they're
just they're indicting Trump to distract
from the hunter binding story no you're
calling in Witnesses
to distract
from the Trump indictments you dummy
you're trying to get your [__]
brainless chuckleheads out there to talk
about Hunter Biden
so that they that so that people so that
they're distracted from the fact that
you're God your Mussolini Jesus your
orange your orange Messiah
is being indicted again he's a criminal
still
we know that's what you're doing because
they made up the story this weekend Jim
corn Jesus Jim Comer and Matt Getz
that's right
um Matt Getz
Jane says is that my coma impression
that's my Comber impression I mean just
do dumb just do dumb and that's your Jim
Comer impression
impersonation impression whatever
Jesus Christ Jim Comer and Matt Gantz
over the weekend claimed that the
Department of Justice was trying to
arrest Devon Archer before he testified
today which is not the truth the
Department of Justice has been working
with Devin Archer's attorneys to try to
get him to set a date to surrender to
serve the prison since sentence which he
was convicted on how the [__] listen ah
this pisses me off so [__] much
that Republicans are yelling and
screaming about a two-tier justice
system
right they expect Devin Archer to come
in and give the [__] give the goods
on Hunter Biden and they don't want him
arrested after he's been convicted
he's he's he's he's he's
done every single amount of appeal that
he possibly can do and he still is not
in [__] prison
he still is not in [__] prison
and they're and they're negotiating with
him
arrest his dumb ass [__] him [__] Devin
Archer any other of us [__] out
there who trust me trust me on this
trust me on this any one of us and other
[__]
especially if you don't look like Devin
Archer if you smell what I'm stepping in
cracker cracker cracker cracker yeah I'm
calling Devon Archer a white man and
rich white man and that's why he was
afforded to be out on [__] appeal in
the first place any other one of us
would have been done been arrested and
served our [__] prison sentence
go arrest his dumb ass [__] him [__]
Devin Archer [__] him go arrest him
who gives a [__] if he can't testify in
front of the house oversight committee
he needs to be serving the jail sentence
that he was [__] sentenced to like
the rest of us would this is this
[__] nonsense about hello they're not
indicting me they're indicting you if
they can do this to me they can do this
to you now you goddamn right if they do
it to us they should be able to do it to
your dumb [__] rich white asses
this is a prime example of it of the
two-tier justice system right [__]
here in front of your face and they're
complaining
they're complaining that the Department
of Justice is going to arrest someone
who has been indicted and convicted
convicted by a jury
exhausted all their appeals and still
they're trying to negotiate when he's
going to surrender to serve his prison
sentence and the [__] and the [__]
house oversight committee Republicans
are bitching about it
do you see do you see what the [__] I'm
talking about when I say there is a
two-tier justice system and they're just
pissed off that Donald Trump and his
privileged little [__] tear of
justice is not protecting him the way
they want
that's the [__] rub that's what
they're saying that's what they're
talking about
and you should be pissed off too
that Devin Archer just gets a walk
around [__] that [__] arrest that
[__]
arrest him the rest of us would have
done served the jail sentence been out
and done our paper too by the time we
exhausted appeal five years later [__]
that guy [__] him [__] Devon Archer and
[__] James Comer [__] Matt gets him [__]
Jim Jordan and [__] the entire
Republican party and the house oversight
committee Republicans [__] them
[__] them because today Devin Archer's
gonna go in and not say [__] about [__]
and in a closed door transcribed
interview and then the Republicans are
going to claim they're gonna claim that
the information is so sensitive that
they can't show people
because there ain't gonna be [__] there
they're full of [__] [__] always have
been always will be [__] them [__] em
[__] em [__] em
but I'll show you the [__] video
still I'll show you and the reason why
I'll show you the video of Devin archers
because no one knows who this guy is no
one gives a [__] who this guy is they
really don't care here I'll show you
there he is there's Devin Archer right
there
that that oh look at that [__]
look at that [__] let me back it
up look at that [__] look at him
right there
oh man he's just happy as a lark isn't
he happy as a [__] lark
that he gets to go in and act like he's
doing something good by going in and
testifying to the house oversight
committee and closed door meeting where
they know the transcript is not going to
be released
and he gets his moment of Fame
in the right-wing conspiracy niche
because no listen listen to me no one
knows who the [__] this is no one gives
a [__] who the [__] this is he's a
criminal and that's basically what the
Department of Justice they released a
memo over the weekend because James
Comer and Matt gatz wouldn't keep their
[__] mouth shuts nor would Charlie
Kirk or Benny Johnson they wouldn't keep
their [__] mouth shut about how oh my
God you're gonna arrest him so he can't
go testify it doesn't matter it doesn't
matter
it doesn't matter any other [__]
would have done been [__] arrested
and the Department of Justice said no
we've been trying to arrest this
[__] for for months we've been
trying to negotiate his release
or excuse me his surrender
for his prison sentence in which he was
convicted and he's exhausted all his
appeals thank you very much and the
department just said he can go do
whatever the [__] he wants he's still
gonna serve his prison sentence
because I believe that's what the
Republicans have lied to Devin aren't
sure about it's like yeah we'll get the
Department of Justice off of your back
if you come testify wink wink
he's dumb as dog [__] stupidest [__]
I've ever heard of it's not it's not
crazy
hmm
so what what the [__] what the [__] is
this about
here's what I said
here's what I say because this guy with
Trump the Trump team or team Trump
whatever the [__] he says former Hunter
Hunter Biden business partner Devin
Archer
he was convicted five years ago Folks by
the way I don't know if you're doing
math of when the five years ago but that
was long before Joe Biden ran for
president but you know who's counting
arrives on Capitol Hill for a closed
door transcribed interview with the
house oversight committee I said a guide
no one has ever heard of and hasn't
served in the Biden Administration shows
up for the government to be weaponized
against him
right after today no one will know who
Devin Archer is but Trump will still be
United
what the [__]
the media sucks that's that's the real
story here is the media sucks they suck
at this they're horrible at this they
don't know how to do this they just
don't they used to they used to be
pretty good before the internet
and before Pro before propaganda was big
on the internet they were they were
pretty good at it but they're not
anymore they're just not
that the media needs to change their
[__] they need to get their [__] [__]
together
like like this this [__] [__] on Fox
News Sunday with Alina Haba Trump's
lawyer
about the [__] employees
that were that were trying to [__]
delete security footage and now they've
been indicted listen I mean they're
in custody of the justice department but
the question is was there an attempt to
try to make sure that didn't happen
well let's be clear if there was an
attempt by somebody who lives in a home
take out president Trump who owns a
company he owns it he owns the I.T he
plea he pays for all these employees if
there was an attempt for him to not turn
over documents or he wanted something
deleted do you not think that that's
something he couldn't have gotten done
let's just use common sense does it say
thank you
oh my God it's such a stupid it's such a
stupid idea that Alina hamba is going on
Fox News Sunday like look okay the thing
that they're accusing him of he
certainly he certainly could have done
that of course he could have who
couldn't do that the person what yet we
know that
we know he's in control he owns
Mar-A-Lago he lives there trying well he
doesn't actually live there because he
can't live there he's got to pretend to
live there
he's got to pretend that he goes to New
Jersey every once in a while because
they won't actually allow him to live
there
yeah he controls the cameras because he
owns it and he can delete evidence if he
because he knows
where the room is where you record the
[__] and you
what okay so what's your point
Alina Haba the American Republic forgets
to use comments I mean that's the
allegation is that he did try and that
these employees said ah we may have to
talk to someone else I don't know that I
can even do that
Shannon I know the facts and the facts
are when President Trump gets a subpoena
it goes to the organization the
organization turns it over that is what
actually happened I was I've been an
attorney for the president during this
whole process and I can assure you that
that is not the case
oh so what she's saying is when when the
organization the business gets the
subpoena for the security footage that
they're the ones you have to hand it
over so Donald Trump definitely
certainly could not wink no Howard no
when or where to delete this evidence
before they turn it over listen he's
indicted because they have evidence that
they tampered with the [__] footage
that they tried to delete the goddamn
closed circuit footage
it's not complicated and the reason why
they're using superseding indictments in
this way and I believe this that Jack
has been holding this underneath his
belt
that's what they do with these super
seating indictments
I don't know if you know that again I'm
not an attorney but they use super
cunitements to pressure low level
conspirators to turn and to flip and to
say yeah yeah I did do that yeah yeah
Donald Trump did tell me to [__]
delete that [__] and I did go try to
delete it
so what they do that's what they're
gonna do
because this the employees the low-level
employees at Donald Trump's Mar-A-Lago
where he's ordering them to do this and
do go get me a [__] Diet Coke wipe my
ass right now change my [__] diaper
where's my Adderall where's my Adderall
Walt get me a Diet Coke right now and
come in here and wipe my stinky ass
after I [__] my drawers because I'm
indicted again
those folks those folks are easy to flip
because they got a lot to lose
they don't have everything
like Donald Trump has
they're just low-level employees that
work at a golf resort
that [__] vacuum his floors and dust
his tables wipe his ass and bring him
Diet Coke and Adderall
okay
so yeah they're gonna flip
and how they get him the flip is they
threaten them the prosecutors threaten
them with charges
and when they still don't flip they they
ring them in as co-conspirators on a
superseding indictment
and that superseding indictment is going
to be a key word
in this documents case and also in the
January 6 case
you're gonna see it because when the
January 6 indictments drop I think
you're gonna go whoa whoa whoa whoa why
isn't this person indicted why isn't
this person indicted what where the heck
what happened to this do we know the
evidence about this person this person
should be on this indictment and that's
because they're using indictment as a
threat to get them to flip
I'm telling you
I'm telling you you can doubt me all you
want go ahead at your apparel doubt me
but that's what they're trying to do
that is what they are going to do is get
the low-level employees to flip on him
that's one reason why they put Walt Nana
on the original indictment they figured
Walt might flip
on an original indictment
he didn't because Donald Trump is paying
for his attorneys because I know how
this goes too
oh man
can you imagine to pay for I'll pay for
your attorneys don't worry I'll pay for
your attorneys you won't have to pay
hundreds of thousands of dollars for
your attorneys if you turned on me
though if you turned on me then you'll
be on your own you'll be out on your ass
you won't have a job you'll have to pay
for your own attorneys
listen
when you know that a retainer fee for a
federal case most federal cases well let
me give an idea most federal cases that
you catch in this country if you're
going to go retain Council which means
you're going to hire an attorney to
represent you in federal court is
anywhere between ten and thirty thousand
dollars just to retain them as your
Council you have to pay them that money
like right now
you're not gonna walk out of their
office with an attorney if you don't
give them 10 15 20 25 30 grand depending
on the case
they're going to require a payment up
front
as a retainer for a federal case these
people now have Federal felonies charged
against them in an indictment
serious ass [__]
and an attorney is going to look at you
and go wow you're indicted federally
that's going to cost you some change
so either these people stay with Trump
and continue to use Trump attorneys
which are only going to make these
people do what they shouldn't do right
which is do more crime by trying to
obstruct and by trying to to get rid of
this indictment and listen all these
people who are going to go to the very
bitter end with Donald Trump are gonna
end up in a federal prison
every [__] last one of them
in this documents case and then this
January 6 case
that's what Jack Smith is doing
when he is using superseding indictments
to try to get these people to flip
and that's the main and that's the main
thing
that's the main thing that you need to
know about these super senior diamonds
everyone's asking where Gabe is at
that's a good question
foreign
I can't wait
can't wait for more indictments I can't
wait I mean it's not going to change
their minds you know what I mean it's
really not going to change these these
trumpets these moglodytes mind the ones
that showed up at his rally this weekend
it ain't gonna change their mind and it
ain't gonna keep people from not boating
from him
I don't know if you've been talking to
some of your Trump relatives out there
that like Trump
I'm telling you they're gonna they like
that he's a crooked criminal they like
that he's the worst version of himself
they like that because they want to be
that they want to be the worst version
of themselves
uh is Gabe hung over uh Arts I ask if is
Gabe hunger I I don't know
could be and I'll have to ask him when
he's here do you want me to ask him if
he's uh if he's feeling a little Saucy
still was he was he drinking last night
is that when
oh boy oh boy
okay so let's let's go back um to some
more clips of
of these trumpladites as we wait for
Gabe Sanchez to join us here I think
Gabe's going to join us today he'll be
here tomorrow with Texas ball for a
little bit and then I think he's got the
uh he needs the rest of week off he's
kind of he's kind of tied up he's he's
got some stuff he's got to do
let's see
oh where is the oh yes oh did you hear
did you hear there were Nazis out and
about this weekend hmm
wouldn't you know in that kind of fun no
I'm not talking about I'm not talking
about the Nazis at the Trump rally I'm
talking about
actual Nazis they I think they call
themselves The Blood Tribe they were in
Watertown Wisconsin speaking of
Wisconsin we're talking about Wisconsin
earlier uh there was a pride in the Park
event at Watertown Wisconsin
so the Republicans showed up
no they're Republicans they're
Republicans
and I mean yeah they're obviously the
Republicans look look you know I mean I
can turn the sound off here but here
here's the Republicans showing up at the
park
and here he is see there's the
Republicans they got their Republican
Pride flags and everything you see that
what do you want from me what the hell
you want from me I again I don't I don't
make these people I don't make these
Republicans go show up these Pride
events
and and carry their their Republican
style Flags what do you want what do you
want from me
this is a a you know what you know I
noticed um too that it looks like
they're really supporting uh uh the new
Twitter logo the X they like the X you
know what I mean they like X's
but again this is Republicans showing up
at a pride event pride in the park and
water Watertown or Waterton is it
Watertown or Waterton Wisconsin
carrying their Republican frags wearing
their Republican regalia look at them
look at him here yes they're Nazis
they're [__] Nazis
yeah crazy part about them this stuff is
is that Republicans
Republicans don't like like when you
call Nazis
I'm not a Nazi you son of a [__]
and you're like do you like moms or
Liberty you're like you goddamn right
they're doing the Lord's work quoting
Hitler and [__]
do you like Liberty University you
goddamn right I like Liberty University
one of the heads over at Liberty
University believes that Hitler did
right by by brainwashing the youth
that's what you got to do so you got to
do the same thing Hitler did I believe
in that
and you're like well you know like Ron
DeSantis what he's doing in Florida like
you goddamn right I'm not a Nazi but I
like what Ron DeSantis is doing in
Florida burning books Banning books
trying to trying to put people on trains
and get rid of people certain groups of
people you know what I'm talking about
that sort of thing
they get mad when we call them Nazis
here's the thing the Nazis
the Nazis think the Republicans are
Nazis
all right
that's how you know
the other the other way you know
if if you're if you're in the company in
Nazis or not is if there's a Nazi
sitting at a table
and there's 10 other people sitting at
the table with that Nazi there's 11
Nazis at the table
that's how it works
that's how it works there's no tolerance
there's no tolerance
for this type of Republican
for Republicans that are left
and if you don't like it if you don't
like it and you get offended that I call
white people or that I call Republicans
Nazis if you get offended by it and
you're all [__] hurt and you're all
snowflakey about it I get up all in your
Fields I'm talking to you you got it
if you're pissed off that I call
Republicans and white people Nazis I'm
talking to you
got it
if you get upset
but look at these Republicans
look at them there's more video of them
there's more video and they're doing the
stupid
[__]
I don't know I I think I glitched there
for a second did I glitch
him boy
did you see speaking of uh
Nazi exes
Twitter has gone down the [__]
Twitter is going down to [__]
um I'm gonna give you a flash warning
here
because if you if you don't like
flashing lights and yeah I'm giving you
a warning here because I'm about to uh I
did glitch yeah for some reason I don't
know it must have been the Deep State
the Deep State Nazis
uh are trying to shut me up but they
just can't shut down my service I think
apparently
now I'm going to give you again a a
flash warning so if you don't like
flashing lights I want to look away for
a minute but I'm gonna do a still shot
here I'm gonna freeze it this is on top
of the Twitter headquarters
this [__] put an unauthorized
lighted sign on top of his uh the
Twitter headquarters with the next
what a dumbass yeah yeah I had a mitch
glitch
Strokes My Goats
do you think I didn't talk about that
last week do you think Mitch McConnell
had a stroke
do you think that's what it was some
people are saying it was a certain type
of seizure or something I thought it
looked like mini strokes
that's what I thought it looked like
maybe I'm wrong you know
maybe you just had to fart
hey man when you get a fart sometimes no
matter what kind of move you make
and especially if you can't trust that
fart you know what I'm talking about
you're not maybe you had bean burritos
the night before
you had runny eggs for breakfast you
know what I'm saying you kind of had a
chocolate milkshake still sitting there
it's gargling oh
and you're in mid-sentence and if you
say one more word you might let out a
toot
and it might it might not go over very
well it might be go over like a wet fart
in a white thong you just might not go
over you sometimes sometimes you just
can't trust a fart
so you got to stop mid-sentence you
don't want to move you don't want to
make any sudden movements you don't want
to win the blow you don't want any kind
of distraction you just gotta stop for a
second
concentrate making sure you don't fart
it could be it it could be it that could
be what the glitch was I think it was
like some people are saying a certain
type of um seizure why not
I thought maybe maybe it was a stroke
some are saying not a stroke of seizure
yeah and I don't know I'm not I'm not a
[__] doctor by any means it seemed as
if Mitch McConnell or as Gabe Sanchez uh
referred to him as glitch McConnell
um needed a doctor but I actually
believe that he could have been trying
to hold in a fart
Gabe what do you think I I what the
actual [__]
uh I I heard that people were wondering
if my hair was going to be wet today no
no no I totally dry what totally totally
dry is that is that the action did you
not do anything to your hair that's what
it's like I had a hat on so that's why
God damn put the hat back on thank you
very much thank you very much for
putting that back on yeah yeah yeah so
we were talking I was gonna show I was
gonna show the X I'm glad you're here
finally yeah because I was going to show
the uh the X on top of um uh uh of
elon's headquarters the [__]
Spotlight the cell signal so but I know
I was giving everyone a flash warning
but I glitched right before that and so
then
glitch McConnell right yeah yeah yeah so
and and I was surmising that it could be
a because I called it I call them stroke
Strokes from a goats a lot of people a
lot of people are like man you're
insensitive like what do you want from
me he's like a thousand years old he
fell down he fell down the steps a
couple months ago hit his it is is
Noggin on the bottom step or some [__]
he was in recovery normally when you
fall like that it isn't the fall that
gives you injury later on it's injuries
um from like trying to recover from the
fall that you have the medical you know
especially when you're a thousand years
old yeah I mean that's how old multiple
times a lot of people I mean a lot there
are a lot of people close to him that'll
be like oh that's like that's worrying
you know the fall that happened and at
the same time you know it's like all
right maybe he shouldn't be there
anymore right well he definitely
shouldn't be there but that was a long
time ago before he started having
strokes and Falls he shouldn't have been
there [__] 30 years ago yeah he
should have been disqualified from being
a member of Congress or the Senate years
and years and decades ago but the point
is this the point is is that
I thought maybe just maybe he had like
bean burritos the night before and for
breakfast he had like runny eggs in a
real big chocolate is like chocolate
milk and it was gurgling you know what
I'm talking about like when you when
you're about to fart and you don't know
if you can trust a fart you don't want
to say anything you don't want to make
any sudden movements you know what I
mean and that feeling in your stomach it
feels like there's going to be an
explosion and you're doing everything
you can to hold your butthole so that
fart doesn't escape you know what I'm
saying I that could be it that could
have been it man he didn't want to [__]
himself right there in front of the
cameras I mean I mean I would I wouldn't
want to [__] myself in front of the
cameras yeah but it's a it's a so it
under I mean like I can understand why
he you know if that were the case right
he was like oh no is it gonna happen and
in that moment the look on his face it
was like he saw the devil except it was
you know just the the lingering thought
of will I [__] my pants today well I
[__] my pants in front of millions of
people watching or who will watch this
clip again and again
well because it would have been obvious
too because everyone behind him would
have went whoa [__] yeah oh my God I
mean who knows maybe some maybe he maybe
he's uh borrowing a pair of Depends from
Donald Trump who by the way I just want
to point out I went to Costco this
weekend yeah
and I made a post now if I made that
post how did you infer like how did you
interpret that that Donald Trump is
[__] his drawers yeah yeah but why
is he [__] his drawers because he's
gonna be indicted again okay yeah yeah
my post said at Costco
should I like buy any for how many
should I buy for Trump right right and
people some people in the comments
everyone else is like oh that's good
that's good that's good yeah some people
were like that's ableist and I go I
never never brought it up look never
mentioned no one no one's shaming anyone
who shits their drawers yeah that says
more about you on what you think you
think and what you want it to be than
what I'm actually saying what I'm saying
is he's in deep [__] he needs [__]
he needs [__] catchers to catch how much
[__] he's in yeah but here's the thing
here's the thing everyone's had that
moment like I've had the moment on a
show I'm not gonna lie folks there's
sometimes I'm sitting here and I got a
[__] like bad like if I'm sweating and
my stomach's going goal and I'm hoping
the microphone ain't picking it up and
I'm just doing everything I can not not
the [__] I mean you could always mute it
you know but if we if you ever see your
face where you go
then we know then yeah right right now
again again if I was in mid-sentence and
then I again
stop oh
Tony if we get like a look around like
oh Tony are you okay uh yeah come on do
you want to say anything else to your
audience
he was gonna [__] his pants I think
that's what it was I totally think
that's what it was
listen I apologize
I apologize to glitch McConnell for us
assuming that he had Strokes when it was
probably he just had to [__] because he
walked away and they went and you know
maybe he did his fart and it wasn't he's
like oh well that wasn't as bad as I
thought and then he came back to the
microphone and he kept speaking and then
he did an interview with CNN and here
here's a Segway you ready for this yeah
go ahead they said well what happened at
the podium he goes oh well I spoke to
president uh President Biden and I told
him I got sandbagged now speaking of
sandbags let's talk about the sign on
top of the Twitter building held down by
sandbags here it is here's here's here's
a uh here's a a still shot now again if
you if you get uh if you have trouble
with flashing lights you're not going to
want to watch this video because
it's obnoxious as [__] I think I said
because you were on your patreon I kind
of raided your your patreon and
um you were talking about how uh Elon
this is this is a perfect example of
Elon and I said he's this is just
symbolism of him just being totally
obnoxious I forget the exact phrase that
I use but he's just
sister he's he's a nuisance an absolute
nuisance and this is an example of this
now this is a correct me if I'm wrong
this is footage from across the road in
an apartment building yeah so there are
there's an apartment building this one
is is uh caddy corner from it so it's
diagonal from the building it's straight
across now to the right
of where this
point of view is there's another
apartment building
and then to the left uh of this building
there are more businesses and stuff like
that so this is Market Street for people
who don't know
in San Francisco Market Street is the
main street it cuts the city in half so
you mean it's like the busiest street
it's yeah it's where all the businesses
are you've got the financial district
down there once you go further down if
you keep going down then you get to
um then you get to the pier right the
Port of San Francisco the the ferry
building that's there you you know you
go along it's where trolleys are and
this and that but along the way you have
all of these buildings that are either
residential or commercial there's a ton
of businesses corporate businesses that
are along Market Street okay Twitter is
in a very iconic historic building
and there's a big reason why this is
causing a big issue is because
you cannot make such changes two said
buildings without permission
design and approval and oversight by the
city the other thing too is he doesn't
own this building exactly and really
he hasn't even paid the rent on the
building apparently since December 2022
because according to Elon he said well I
got this company and it's losing like
four million dollars a day that's what
he told people could be more could be
less who knows which company
Twitter wait I thought it was called X
it's it's it's
so he says I'm losing four million
dollars a day I can't be expected wait
wait wait wait hold on wasn't Twitter
profitable before he bought it
no it wasn't profitable at all it wasn't
making any was it losing four million
dollars a day I don't know if it was
losing 4 million that's what he says it
was losing oh that knows if that's true
okay go ahead guy just making sure I do
know that they weren't making money
because it is a a global entity with a
lot of people a lot of offices and a lot
of things that they're trying to do
overhead wise so
what happens is he takes over uh and
then in December 2022 he's like I'm not
going to pay the rent anymore this is uh
this is just like totally not right wait
wait wait I just thought of something
you're telling me I know I know I'm
getting off track here are you telling
me that Elon is such a smart businessman
that he paid 44 billion dollars for a
company that doesn't make any money
yeah yeah wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait
oh no wait where where in the world is
the genus in this
where is the genius in this I don't know
what the hell's going on I don't know
hang on with me so what happens you're
attacking with me
I think that's the Deep State listen
here's the thing okay
is you're telling me he's so smart that
he paid 44 billion dollars for a company
that's losing 4 million dollars a day
supposedly
this makes him smart
that's what he says wait wait I thought
he was supposed to be a genius at this
stuff
yes he's supposed to be a big big rocket
scientist genius so you would think that
a genius if he's gonna be waiting for
he's gonna pay 44 billion dollars for a
company that was losing 4 million
dollars a day you would think
within about a year of owning it he
would have turned that [__] around right
yeah you think he would have turned that
around and also he said that's what he
said all he's done is just put an x on
the top of the building here well he's
not only did that right before doing the
X he made a logo that's actually based
on a font that's based on a guy who had
a podcast that was simping for Elon Musk
so he took a logo wait he start you're
saying he stole it he didn't actually
come up here he took it but well
claiming okay here's the story here's
the story there was a there was an Elon
simp he had a podcast that was all about
the companies that Elon has right and in
that podcast it had a logo and the logo
is very similar to the x that is used
um for for Twitter now
and people were like
because he said hey here here's a logo
Elon you can use it if you want no big
deal it's all yours people are like hey
this logo looks pretty similar there's
already a
um there's already a Unicode
um
right like a font there's a yeah there's
a font there's a symbol that's already
inherently in every system that can
identify that X right
and then you've also got this guy who
was like oh I designed this logo what he
did was he bought rights to the font to
use and then he slightly modified the
logo I think maybe so wait the guy that
Elon stole it from stole it is that what
you're saying he bought the No No he
bought the rights to a logo right to a
font and then but then he said
I designed it this isn't typical Elon
fashion right yeah this is the this is
the mo of this idiot in his Sims yeah
yeah so he says I designed it you can
have it if you want everyone then on the
internet was like okay hold on hold on
you didn't design this and then he went
back and said okay maybe I didn't design
it it was just like modified slightly
again do not take credit for something
you know I I've never I don't ever make
fonts but I appreciate the art and the
the time and effort that it goes into
making set fonts some of these fonts I
don't know if you guys went out on the
internet and go to like a font website
yeah to see how many there are and like
how many different designs there's
millions of them there's millions of
them and I don't even know how they get
started on making a font to be quite
honest it seems very confusing but yeah
but there's all kinds of you can get
ones that look like like the Ninja
Turtles font you can get ones that look
like all these other uh Brands
yes so this guy bought right to the font
he modified it slightly
he used it as a logo then put it on
Twitter and said here Elon you can have
it Elon then takes it it's a thinner
version at one point then people say
whoa this is very similar to this other
one that's already that it is that is
open source like
what's going on here open source meaning
anyone can use anyone can use no
training and then what happens is it's
revealed that meta has the rights to a
the trademark X so now you've got Elon
who says we're going to make this
everything app it's gonna be cause it's
going to be called X and Twitter is
going to be the accelerant or X is going
to be the accelerant to make it or yeah
no Twitter is going to be the accelerant
to creating X the everything app so so
wait a second let's back up to the to
the trademarks because from my
understanding is that meta or or
Facebook Mark Zuckerberg owns the
trademark for X in the social media
platform yes but Microsoft owns it for a
financial yes so his
so either one he goes whether it's
social media or making it in everything
app he does not own the trademark
doesn't own the trademark
um yeah I mean it's so shitty that the
new tagline yeah of Twitter is Blaze
Your Glory
full
Blaze Your Glory
hole this is what that's the actual
official it's Blazer Glory exclamation
point I just added she was right they
might as well add them yeah but here's
the thing yeah here's the thing though
you you pointed out this weekend
um that on like the Apple Store he can't
actually call it X he has to still call
it Twitter so they did they did change
it last night early this morning so
apple apple did give it a purpose
[__] those who used to be it used to
be the minimum character limit of two
and now you can have one but I love
people who are like this is fake news
this is a real no no you're making this
[__] up because people were coming at my
comments after I said this brand this
Rebrand is DOA Dead on Arrival right
right and so the idea that
what I said was false is is not false I
where is true it got updated this
morning but it was funny to see people
like freak out and all these like Elon
fans you're not wrong stop spreading
fake information and I go here's the
articles that break this down here's
someone who was uh who actually went
through as a developer and tried to get
approval for an app with only one letter
there's a room and it went through and
it's like here's a documentation this is
why you can and can't do it this is the
first time that a company has been
allowed this special change
well there's a lot of there's a lot of
stuff that elon's being allowed to do
including this sandbag situation this
stupid [__] sign because apparently
the inspectors have not been able to
allow to get in the building which is
all [__] listen call the police
department San Francisco Police
Department have them come down and say
hey we're going to escort these
inspectors to your sign and they are
going to [__] I wouldn't be surprised
if that happens this week and if you
don't like it I will [__] arrest you
Elon Musk that's what we will do and we
will ask anyone who obstructs us but
here's here is the these are the Law and
Order people right these are the Law and
Order people but here's the image none
of these people are wearing protective
helmets none of these only one dude on
the on the is wearing your harness is
wearing some kind of harness the other
guy's on a ladder the dude on the bottom
is like holding it up the guy in the top
is holding it up he's got his little
cherry picker
these people
are are whole are are barely holding on
to this structure right and some people
say like oh these are temporary yeah
okay
um if I'm going to install something
heavy on the end that faces a
public-facing Street Market Street with
the ability for this thing to topple
over and kill someone you you want you
want my opinion on what's going on here
yeah okay so
um now I don't know the building codes
in San Francisco but I've had to deal
with a lot of building codes before
um I used to have a company where we
would build really big buildings and
sometimes we'd have to really we'd have
to get with counties and cities and all
kinds of inspections and make sure
everything's just right before the
building goes up and when the building
goes up again I haven't inspected
afterwards make sure it's just right the
engineering they want the engineering
plans and all this because it's a
permanent quote permanent structure and
the reason why they're not permanently
attaching this to this building is
because they probably can't right now
they can't permanently attach this
because if they do they will really be
in trouble number one because they don't
own the building okay number one they do
not own the building number two it is
probably a really really really
expensive thing to not only attack hatch
it and be fine but then to unattach it
so the reason why they're making this
temporary and the reason why they're
sandbagging this as it were because
that's literally what they're doing
they're using the weight of the sandbags
you can see the strap if you look
closely you see the strap over the
sandbags and they're on both sides of
this um of this structure here they're
they're using this to say oh this isn't
permanent this is a this is just this is
just a gag and I would almost bet that's
what elon's going to do when these
inspectors finally do say you got to
take this [__] thing down this is not
safe this is you do not have this
approved you can't number one the
structure is unsafe number two you're
[__] flashing a light into the
buildings across the street at all hours
of the night and you're literally strobe
lighting them you got to take this
[__] down we're gonna make you
take it down and when he takes it down
he's gonna go hahaha it was all a joke
so funny it's so funny which I mean is
the same reason why he owns Twitter in
the first place because cause it was a
big [__] joke but I almost guarantee
you that's why they had to they had to
come up with the structure that wasn't
permanent because not only would the
landlord probably not approve for them
to permanently attach anything like this
but the city and the county or who else
else has jurisdiction over the building
codes in San Francisco on Market Street
yeah no telling who who I I you know I
don't know specifically on Market Street
who has the jurisdiction there but my
guess is is that way that's why they
made this temporary so they'd get away
with [__] because that's what he's
trying to do because uh yeah what you
mentioned is right he doesn't own this
building Twitter never owned this
building the people that are tenants in
this building if I remember correctly
when I I've been there so many different
times
Thumbtack it's like a third party
Service uh you can buy you can get
people to to do like it's like a
taskrabba kind of thing you get people
with specialized Services
um you have Twitter you have uh SF
Fitness which is a gym it was a it's
kind of like a Gold Gym in SS they're
all in the same building all in the same
building what you need to realize is
that this bill so not only does he not
own the building but this building was
originally constructed or part of the
building was originally constructed in
1937. the other part was in 1974. the
reason that he can't make changes this
is because this building
is a historic building right it's on a
registry exactly and historic buildings
have specific codes and approvals and
you know if you're trying to renovate
you're trying to make changes you have
to fall in line with certain things that
do not disrupt its original appearance
which is mainly the outside and the
owner and the owner buying the building
whoever owns it and probably knew that
when they bought it it's the same thing
in like a lot of towns of Massachusetts
and the reason why out out east uh you
have a lot of these building codes like
that for specific buildings and specific
houses is because a lot of that [__] is
really old and they pass laws they pass
codes that hey we have to keep the
historic value of this town you know
that's the thought that's a thought
process yeah and that's just how they do
it but but the thing the thing that
really [__] gets in my crawl here is
not that he's trying to escape the the
actual laws by sandbagging this thing as
it were
but the obnoxious nature of the light
Jesus [__] like this is the symbolism if
nothing represents Elon more than this
and again I'm going to warn the audience
if you have like a a flashing thing that
causes you to have uh disoriented or
whatever it is there's a lot I mean if
you suffer from epilepsy yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah well even if you don't
like flashing lights yeah you're gonna I
mean there's something I know I I get
migraines
um I suffer from them since I was a kid
and light sensitivity is definitely
something that's there and it can also
be triggered by light sensitivity right
um so the this
this is not only a public nuisance but
it is a a health safety hazard for
anyone in that building because I would
imagine that at least one person let's
say in that building of hundreds of
units
might suffer from something and if that
light flickers in there in their eyes
and it triggers them to I don't know
have a seizure or have some sort of uh
you know attack or maybe there are some
people out there who don't know that
they suffer from epilepsy and it takes
it it just happens right right so so
again again if you have sensitivity to
that I'm I'm warning you here's my
warning because I'm going to show that
because you got to see if you can watch
it you gotta it's not listen it's not
even a good light show like it would be
different if this thing gave off a good
show but it's not even a good light show
he's just being [__] Elon he's just
being [__] annoying so here it is I'm
gonna play it now you can watch I'm
gonna I'm gonna mute it but so because
we're gonna talk over you can see it's
really bright and it just kind of phases
in and out and you know it's not so
Blinky and strobe Lighty right now
um but and this is a this is uh someone
taking a video from their camera from
across the street right that's what this
is now there's other videos where it is
like strobing and and it doesn't even
look cool and you can't even really tell
that this thing's an X to be quite
honest yeah um the other thing that I
think is important here about this is
that
Air Traffic Control has to hate this
[__]
yes and the reason why is because a lot
of lights that are put on buildings are
lights that are supposed to identify the
building for aircraft helicopters and
other things and this thing is bright as
[__]
so I I don't I and I don't know in in
San Francisco where the
like uh where some of this aircrafts
would be and stuff but I mean the
closest aircraft that you would see that
comes over right so there's the Oakland
Airport which is on the other side of
the bay and then there's SFO which is
south of the bay the only air travel
that you would see in that part of SF
would be uh
a a police helicopter or a news
helicopter or something like that but
it's very bright and and I think the
thing that kind of pisses me off the
most about this because like as someone
who lived in San Francisco Elon made
this post this weekend and he said oh
um
let me see if I can find it really quick
he's basically lying but he made a post
early this week when he got busted for
trying to take down the original Twitter
sign right this iconic Twitter sign that
was on the side of the building he was
taking it down and then he got busted
sfpd showed up turns out
you know they didn't not that according
to what was said they didn't need a
permit but they certainly didn't block
off the street or the sidewalk to make
sure that you know God forbid something
[__] Falls and hurts someone not that
he actually cares but what happens is
Elon this weekend made a post that said
um you know he's like oh people want us
to go they've offered us money to take
the building or to have us move to
another city or something but I'll never
do that I'll never abandon you San
Francisco I know that you're in a doom
spiral but I will tell you right now
that we are here for good now the reason
he said that and people need to remember
that what he's doing is he's trying to
okay Elon said many have offered
Rich incentives for X formerly known as
Twitter to move its HQ outside of San
Francisco moreover the city is in a doom
spiral with one company after another
left or leaving therefore they expect X
will move too we will not you will know
your uh you only know your who your real
friends are when the chips are down Elon
doesn't have any friends San Francisco
beautiful San Francisco though others
forsake you we will always be your
friend Elon [__] hates SF and he's
trying to make it sound like oh no no
we're not leaving
because people want us to leave we're
not we're not going to leave because we
have nowhere else to go and people need
to realize that what he's trying to do
here is he's trying to reinvent or or
you know in a revisionist type of way
he's facing multiple lawsuits from all
the different places that he doesn't pay
rent for Twitter's offices and his only
option right now is to actually stay
where he is in squat or else he would
have to move to a new office and when
you move to an office they say okay
great we need money up front we need a
deposit we need collateral we need to
make sure that you're going to pay this
so that's right they have to pay to
redesign and read because there is the
whole negotiation when you move in
somewhere then they say oh we want you
to come in so we'll help remodel this
we'll do this we'll cover the cost here
but when it comes to Twitter Elon has no
choice he has to stay in that building
or else he has nowhere else to go I mean
you look at Boulder Boulder had a judge
that approved the eviction of Twitter
because Elon wasn't paying rent and
remember he hasn't been paying rent
since uh December of 2022 so now what
he's doing is you know the petty little
dick no hair cuck of a man that Elon is
is now trying to take it out on those
who are in San Francisco and for a guy
who says oh San Francisco While others
may have uh where others forsake you we
will always be your friend well I'm
pretty sure that someone who really does
love the city wouldn't emit a [__]
led beam that causes seizures across the
street for people who are just trying to
[__] sleep
well Loki puts the exclamation point on
it x marks the [__]
pretty simple that's yeah that's I mean
that we could have just said that x
marks the [__]
speaking of what speaking of [__] did
you see what this [__] gray gut field
said this weekend about that oh my god
dude
he's having uh the last week first he
was like oh yeah the people who were in
a concentration chapter yeah
the ones who survived you know what they
learned they learned how to stack dead
bodies like a [__] that's a
skill you can take with you when you
leave a concentration campus it's quite
learn how to stop the dead bodies of
your family members that's a hell of a
skill you can take with you great great
gutville thinks it is but here's Greg
Gutfeld on deleting surveillance footage
this is [__] wild [__] and then I got
I got like a a quick round of videos I
want to show you uh Trump videos over
the weekend but let's watch great gut
they'll try to tell us why destroying
evidence in a federal criminal case is
not that big of a deal the Dems that's
the only work they do that's the only
that when I was listening to that
Montage I felt 2015 all over again the I
actually used the same phrase mafioso
right that was exactly hasn't CNN
learned what that did to their brand I
mean they're barely conscious right now
as a as a as a network and this is
amazing timing timing as the as the uh
Hunter sure its plea deal falls apart
suddenly these new charges on Trump just
happen to arrive and then what about
surveillance cameras what's wrong with
that what's wrong with like if are those
yours why can't you please why can't you
clear them I don't understand that
they're not like other people's emails
that you then you know disappear he runs
straight into it like straight into it
he's like oh yeah we accused Hillary of
deleting emails for years and that's a
really big deal because they're they're
her emails what's the big deal Greg
they're her emails what's the big deal
they're hers why why would deleting them
be such a big deal right you know well
it's not only her emails but it was her
server right right she owned it it was
in her house you know her emails she can
do whatever you want right right it was
in her house if that's the case you guys
are making then stop trying to say but
her emails all right but her private
server
you know the good news you can't say
that you know the good news
you know there's Mike Lindell my pillow
guys got an answer to it let's no talk
to General Flynn today and and he is
actually one of a few people uh uh
there's about 11 people that have been
shown the complete plan that um that
we've been working on for over a year
include this includes the people that
help me with it right right and he
looked at this plan and he said you know
he's a general because they got plans
all the time and he said it's beautiful
he doesn't see any holes in it he
actually added a couple things and he's
going to come on my show hopefully
tomorrow night everybody
um uh we've been working hard every day
18 hours a day now 18 hours a day every
day up until and for the last month uh
working on this event getting the agenda
ready it's like uh did you catch
anything he said do you know what he
[__] he's talking about this guy is so
off the [__] rails man this guy is so
desperate remember gonna happen to a
better guy let me tell you goodness I
covered it I covered it what was that
where I talked about the fact that that
Mike Lindell said they did a cancel
culture on us no that's just [__]
crazy man
insane conspiracies and private
companies can you know decide what they
want to do with the contract whether
they want to work with you or not and
now Mike Lindell you know he says a
hundred million dollars was was uh was
lost because of this whole uh this
cancel culture on him for the election
claims and conspiracies isn't he's been
spreading come afterwards then he said
he invested 40 million dollars so I
don't know if that was part of the 100
million or if that means he's down 140
million dollars then he's got this uh
election fraud Summit which is basically
like his cyber Symposium rebranded
because now he's going to be
suggesting new ways to prevent this from
ever happening in the future as if
anyone in a voting machine
industry or anyone who is ever in charge
of saying this is how we count balancer
this is how we regulate this or that
whatever actually listened to this guy
this is the guy who owned himself during
the 2021 cyber Symposium when he made
claims that there was voter fraud and
then had and then was proven wrong in
real time
this is also the same guy that during
the said 2021 cyber Symposium kept
playing the same 15-minute trailer clip
because they didn't they didn't have
food for people to eat they had little
snacks they didn't have any evidence to
present they had multiple technical
problems with the computers which is
kind of ironic and then they just would
not actually give anything that people
asked for in terms of show me the
evidence show me the proof and they're
like yeah we will we will we'll come
back just watch this clip again and
after the 10th time everyone's like why
are we here and out of that one was the
guy who probably won't get paid because
Mike Lindell doesn't have five million
to his name but there is the guy who was
a trump supporter he voted for Trump
who proved Mike Lindell wrong in his
owed five million dollars because Mike
Lindell decided to say I will pay anyone
five million dollars if they can prove
that these claims are not real and the
guy did didn't take that long I've got a
guy here
um with a video clip who's excited that
Mike Lindell is still lying and he's
sticking to his lies because Steve dice
diese maybe Steve diesel this guy until
this weekend yeah I've never heard of
him either
um but he's really pissed off that
they're not still lying listen to what
he has to say this is on Blaze network
if you know what Blaze network is it's
Glenn Beck's Network let's listen yeah
we are going to the mattresses for these
people we are offering them more
accommodation
more chances than we'd offer our own
family members for goodness sakes
and for what to have Rudy Giuliani go
down to Georgia and admit that he lied
have Jason Miller until the January 6th
commission yeah
we all know it was BS what what what is
this
some of you don't like it when I use the
cult word but when you like being
treated like a schmuck and ask for more
that is a cult
I'm the Mark I'm the sucker I want to be
such
okay so it appears Steve is mad that
manga is a cult and I actually don't
think that's what this is because if you
continue to listen to him what he's
really mad about is that he knows
they're lying he knows it's all [__]
yeah the problem is it's all falling
apart and they won't continue to lie
that's what he's really pissed off about
he's like look I've lied for you for for
six goddamn years I continued to lie for
you and now all of a sudden now all of a
sudden you're not gonna lie anymore and
you expect me to still lie what the [__]
is this [__] he's really pissed off
let's listen to him because a lot of
people are like oh this is manga falling
apart this is not manga falling apart
this is them trying to get the lies back
together for a second for a second
coming of trump listen there's a bit of
a Humpty Dumpty going on here right
right listen here the person who tries
to get me out of that
those are marks of
group think frankly
how many people in this audience sent
money to stop the steal three years ago
here we go
listen
how many shows did I waste your time
talking about this three years ago he
destroys his own credibility this is
insane I love it keep going Steve keep
going baby I've not recovered between
the election fraud and covid
I probably have the smallest Facebook
following of any major show in this
entire industry
yeah because Trump sucks it's like we
won't ban you because then you'll just
you'll whine about it and and generate a
bunch of publicity so we'll just make it
that no one sees your material at all
because it sucks it sucks Steve that's
why I went to the mattresses on Coven in
the election fraud issue because you're
an asshat only to have Rudy Giuliani say
yeah I was lying yep and Jason Miller
say oh we know it's obvious
uh
this guy's having a real coming to Jesus
moment
he got [__] that's what happened they
these people don't understand what's
going on all Steve realizes this Steve
realizes this but but his audience still
is like no no Steve's delusional yeah
they're like no no no no that can't be
that can't be that can't be I'm way too
smart I'm way too smart for that I'm way
too smart for that what's this tweet you
sent me here this is uh
interview that's done that's that's
happening it's update that's happening
right now with the hunter Biden stuff is
this is this the uh the the hunter
Biden's business partner that I talked
about Devin Devin Archer Devin Archer
even sounds fake Denny he looks fake
I mean he doesn't sound like he's a
legit person but also it sounds like
they didn't really make the case that
they were looking to make oh wait wait
wait I I know the audience heard me when
I said the reason why they're only
transcribing this in a closed door
meeting and the Republicans are going to
say well we can't listen we can't
release the transcript because there's
too much sensitive information we can't
let this samples in it might get out
that's what they're gonna say that's
what they're gonna say it's all [__]
folks all of it uh here's a here's a
clip from CNN about it
yeah Brianna no one disputes that Hunter
Biden and Devin Archer were business
associates and that the two of them did
engage in various foreign dealings but
House Republicans have insisted that
Archer could provide a Smoking Gun piece
of evidence that connects the president
to his son's foreign dealings and we're
learning now after a one Democratic
member of the House oversight committee
emerged from this three-hour meeting now
it's still going on the emergence said
look this testimony has offered no proof
connecting the president to his sons for
dealings Congressman Dan Goldman the
Democrat on the committee did say that
you know Archer testified that Hunter
and his son Joe Biden did speak
um every day that at times Hunter Biden
would be in a setting where there would
be business partners present but not
once according to Goldman can I just say
something here this guy looks like
Hunter Biden before he started banging
prostitutes and doing below I'm just
gonna say that
like the
work with the people right
similarities they got nice teeth which
I'm sure are veneers right hey guys
this guy's smiling social cordial people
just like Gunner Biden he looks just
like Hunter Biden yes yeah yeah is he
Hunter Biden's body double is that what
this is could be maybe he was the one
having these phone calls trying to take
Millions he's probably all the ones in
the pictures on the laptop I'm just
saying I'm just saying I don't know I'm
not trying to spend any conspiracy
theories out there
all right let's keep going did these
dealings ever come up so you know Jim
Jordan a republican member of the
committee also has left the interview
um Republicans seem like they're done
with their questioning Jordan didn't
have a lot to say called the beating
productive but um Goldman by comparison
spoke to reporters for at length so
we're really getting the first details
of what Archer is saying in this
interview you know Democrats now he
didn't say [__] look here's the story
you want to know what the truth is I
know what the truth is before Devin
Hunter hit the ground in Washington D.C
the truth is the reason why the
Republicans pulled Hunter Archer or
excuse me Devin Archer whatever the [__]
his name is Hunter Biden's Hunter
Biden's body double Devin Archer into a
[__] meeting a closed-door transcribe
meeting for the house oversight
committee is because they knew what
would happen if Daniel Goldman would
have been able to [__] ask him
questions in the open court or an open
committee meeting with the [__]
cameras he would have made fools of
Republicans that's what would have
happened that's why they didn't do it
that's why they made up this stupid
[__] story over the weekend that
somehow Devin Devin Archer was going to
be arrested by the doj listen folks let
me tell you something no one knows who
the [__] Devin Archer is no one they
don't give a [__] about Devin Archer and
tomorrow no one will know who Devin
Archer is besides a [__] few internet
trolls like yeah what about Kevin Archer
huh what about that and everyone's gonna
who the [__] is Devon Archer who the
[__] is this he was Hunter Biden's
business partner over a decade ago he
was convicted of a crime that they're
trying to get him in prison for that
he's reached and exhausted all his
appeals five years ago he's the epitome
of a two-tier justice system that you
[__] keep yelling and screaming
that's why Trump is being oppressed get
the [__] all yesterday they spent the
whole day saying that boj is trying to
arrest Devon Archer ahead of his
bombshell testimony on Monday when
really that's not at all what happened
not according to Archer and his own
attorney that is the opposite the letter
that was sent sent out as seeks that
Archer set a date to begin his jail
sentence on an unrelated prior
conviction the doj is not coming to get
Devin Archer because of Joe binder
Hunter Biden it's because the Dude
there was a crime he committed said
crime he was charged and now it has to
do with the sentencing of a prior
conviction there was a trial he was
convicted
he's going to jail it happened related
it's going to happen just like speaking
of going to jail and going to prison did
you see
over the weekend Donald Trump goes to
like this Iowa I think we miss this on
Friday he goes to this [__]
conference
yeah and he goes he goes up on stage
here's the music that they play when he
enters on stages Brooks and Dunn song
listen to the words just listen real
carefully
[Applause]
[Music]
so he gets up on stage one could end up
going to prison as soon as his feet hit
the stage can't get any more Beauty I
don't know who timed it but it was great
there it is whoever was on that
soundboard or whoever thought hey we
should totally play this song and
somebody said yeah we should and then
the timing and he was like yeah
this pump jerk off them giraffes
you know I'm surprised that Donald Trump
doesn't have like massive biceps and
triceps from all those like air jerk
offers are you kidding me come on come
on now get over that Okay let's listen
let's listen to his to his little excuse
here because I think this is an eye with
dude now this is
um this is on Breitbart someone from
Breitbart notice the guy who's
interviewing him real quick it's not
like 30 second clip he says some really
crazy nonsense in this what I want you
to take a look at is the guy
interviewing him seriously looks like
Donald Trump shaved his head like buzz
cut his head just his watch man you know
trust me here and don't hang on let me
show you this is harassment this is
election interference uh unprotected by
the presidential records act uh no
you're not totally it shouldn't even be
a case it's not a criminal case it
totally is Biden with all the documents
he's got 20 times 30 times the documents
I have and he has not made it easy
this any boxes to Chinatown
boxes are being sent to Chinatown yeah
China is paying them millions of dollars
you explain that one there it is look at
that
am I wrong or am I wrong this guy
totally looks like Donald Trump as a bud
cut am I right I can see it yeah yeah
I'm totally right I'm totally right now
he says something about he keeps saying
this thing about Chinatown where they
don't speak English right Chinatown
Chinatown he just likes to say China
that that's how this is
Janet Jenna
Jenna do you think he's you think he
likes to say China because it rhymes
with vagina do you think that's why I
mean he loves to grab it never thought
about it without consent maybe that's
maybe that's what this is Jennifer
[Music]
you gotta grab the vagina
well let's let's check this uh China
let's fact check this Chinatown thing if
see if anyone speaks English they're in
China hey what's up I'm Barry we're in
Washington DC's Chinatown and we're
gonna do some fact checking from Donald
Trump's town hall on CNN last night
here's what Trump said why did you take
those documents with you when you left
the White House every right to Biden on
the other hand he had boxes sent to
Chinatown where they don't speak even
English
uh What uh language do you speak English
what what language do you speak English
English speak English yes okay English
there you have it uh people in in this
Chinatown do you speak English
vagina 10 they don't speak they don't
speak English
in town it's the best you don't
you love it I love it I grab it you get
it
Jenna Jenna vagina China China vagina I
don't know why why does he he says that
word a lot he he likes it he loves them
Jenna Jenna Jenna Jenna Jenna Jenna
Jenna Jenna Jenna Jenna Jenna Jenna well
maybe it's because his supporters have
have China brain because they can't stop
with the China brain stuff
baby uh I want to show you a couple
clips of his supporters this weekend in
Pennsylvania hang on to your seats strap
yourself in these are wild
these other people these on both sides
they're in it for themselves for their
pocketbooks for their power Trump isn't
one of them yeah unless you have a very
very large mouth yes he does but you
know what it's it's what it is it's
black and white you don't like them you
don't like them but don't persecute him
for his opinions don't persecute me for
my opinions don't persecute these
children for their opinions
I don't know what the [__] she's talking
about the funny thing is she exactly
describes Donald Trump she's like oh
these [__] [__] grifting taking
money just for money and power running
for president just so they could save
their ass so they don't end up in prison
these [__] and then she's like
but that ain't Donald Trump like what he
just you perfectly describe him what the
hell is going on here well I mean that's
the Republican Party those are the
people that follow him they are able to
say the very thing right and you're
about to play a clip of this one yeah
have you seen the follow-up clip no send
it to me this one here this when they're
interviewing this guy the wildest part
about it is not that they the Trump
supporter because he is inebriated
there's no way you can't convince me
this guy isn't under the influence of
alcohol no [__] way look I've been to
a ton of bars just in the last week I
know on inebriated I've been inebriated
in the last week or two okay a couple
times maybe four it's possible six the
point is this the point is this that
this guy says what he says but the
craziest part is the rsbn reporter who's
on the microphone's like yeah it sounds
about right what what listen to what he
says see if you can catch what he wants
to do to all of them good good I'm here
to I guarantee Trump gets back in and
get rid of the corruption that's in the
white house right now it's a disgrace
these are just nobody's just straight to
this country disgrace and so are all the
uh for the left and the uh rhinos the
globalists they Gilmore
[Laughter]
he says kill them all and and the host
of the microphone's like yeah I agree
yeah yeah yeah yeah anyway so what about
you so he agreed he agreed the line was
Kill Them All We gotta kill him he goes
yeah gotta do it yeah so let's see what
what is what is this this is now this is
not I was like I'm gonna have to do what
was that on this because this is so
[__] insane uh this isn't this right
after this is not right after this later
this is inside waiting for Trump to show
up so it's that reporter with Brian
Glenn who is Marjorie Taylor Green's
boyfriend and he makes his announcement
I forget if Brian Glenn comes in this
but he makes he makes a statement that
basically like I just want to clarify
what was said I wasn't agreeing with
what he said no that's what you said
that's what you said you agree this
thing that is is trending on Twitter
right now yeah because you said you're
interviewing a number of people you were
talking about yeah how great the country
is how great uh the president is that's
not what he said I heard something else
that
was spoken but somebody like what I'm
hearing that is was said was somebody
said well let's kill them all yeah it's
not something that I agree with
obviously uh so if there is something
that happened where somebody was
speaking out there I didn't hear those
words
outside all I know is I'm here for God
for this country
for president Trump that kind of thing
definitely not proponent of anything
like that happening what's this guy's
name what's this guy's name I don't know
what a [__] [__] let me let me look
dude [__] man we heard what you said you
said what you said yesterday there was
no one else talking to him he said
that
he agreed yeah I agree a statement of
the guy said it twice the guy said it
twice kill them all kill them all yeah
yeah come on come on [__] those
[__] and he was the one that
set up the ball on a t for the guy to
say kill them all you noticed that right
he's like yeah what about all them
leftist Marxist Democrat rhinos people
what would you do with them well here's
a bunch of buzzwords I'd put him on a
train and ship them to a concentration
camp and kill them all sounds familiar
sounds familiar listen folks and again
this Trump supporter that he's talking
to Matthew Alvarez Matthew Alvarez BN
host Matthew Alvarez now I will I will
warn you be nice but go give Mr Alvarez
what you think about his little I didn't
say I want to kill him already that's
not what I was saying he's like I was I
was I was wrong
so the guy who was interviewing was
totally wasted right
what's going on is he is drunk but
there's always a possibility that it's
not what do you think what do you think
that Trump supporter drinks what do you
think he's drinking
you could drink meth right
I don't know if that's like a shot you
can order at the bar yeah I'll take four
no you could I thought yeah four mess
you put some meth crystals in some water
and you just like Let It seep like tea
and it's like okay you want me to bring
your mess back to the table oh no
they're all for me I'll do them right
now yeah uh yeah it's like when you go
to the theater and you buy a large
bucket of popcorn and you get a refill
you're like I'll just take the refill
now right I'll just take it right now
right it's good which by the way which
by the way if you're with multiple
people that is the hack that you do you
get the refill right there so when
you're in the theater you have to get
out speaking of weird people who try to
drink this guy here Ron DeSantis I want
to I I wanna I don't want to ignore this
before we leave
crystal meth light is that a queer beer
I don't know Sam won him woke beers
because you know you know what's funny
it'll definitely keep you awoke Ron
DeSantis here the guy the Florida
fascist here who thinks if you go woke
you go broke he doesn't know he's
drinking coolers light Coors Light is a
is a game I was trying to figure out if
that was Coors Light because I didn't
see no it is he orders it no he ordered
he ordered it because Laura Loomer
posted some [__] about him going to the
bar he doesn't know how to order a beer
which he does look awkward when he's
ordering it and the lady at the bar the
bartender's like yeah we got a credit
card uh they want they want to buy you
beers so just whatever you want he's
like whose credit card you have and she
says a Pax name
she says a Pax name so a pack was buying
beer directly for Ron DeSantis which I
don't know if there's legal consequences
or not but anyways that's the thing but
here here's Ron DeSantis trying to act
like a human in front of another human
while drinking a human product uh Coors
Light watch this this is [__] awkward
it is Ron DeSantis though
well we're uh I'm here I don't know
okay all right
that's good
it's gay
okay let's go let's go wait wait is
there is there humans we're going to
talk to are we going to interact with
humans this is a good time to go empty
the human receptacle are we I have to go
knowing I have to go release my bowels
are we going and then he just goes but
the idea that he's like
me drink beer me do human meat talk to
human
you know another Awkward Moment In The
Ron DeSantis um uh slip and slide here
according to you let's let's watch this
this is hilarious with me as the nominee
you know we're going to focus on yeah
that's what the election will be about
if Donald Trump is the nominee it's
going to be about all those other issues
with all due respect Governor you're
down by 30 points though
well no I mean that that says you I mean
I can tell you we've been in Iowa I'm
the one showing up at all these places
we're signing up people uh day after
listen I I paid a lot of money to be
here in Iowa to be down 30 points okay
that just says yeah it's really it's
really an accomplishment honestly but I
would love I would love I would love if
he even gets past Donald Trump because
there's no there's no [__] chance he
gets past him
but if there was some crazy thing like
Donald Trump uh you know ended up
kicking it right uh or something along
those lines don't tease me don't tease
me what I'm saying is though if he did
actually have the the balls to show up
and actually debate Joe Biden I can't
imagine he'd have a very successful time
because he says we're going to talk
about Biden's failures all right let's
talk about the economy let's talk about
jobs let's talk about student loans
let's talk about housing let's talk
about these are all different things at
either he is directly impacting or or
working on legislation right now and is
approved or it is something on the list
that he is going to work on let's talk
about infrastructure let's talk about
the chipset let's talk about this let's
talk about covid
find me and I'm sure everyone has a
failure or a thing that you can consider
a failure but if you're going to go from
the
big accomplishments you have a hard time
there Ron you can't even you can't even
win against Disney what makes you think
you can win the United States
ah he's such a dumb [__] he should have
listened to me months ago you should
have listened to me months ago and he'd
be wildly ahead of where he's at he'd at
least be down by 28 points instead of
30. instead of 30. oh we we have footage
up and we have footage just in for
Mar-A-Lago
um here is uh security footage that was
deleted it's Donald Trump driving around
trying to find the evidence that he
needs to delete uh
uh as we leave you here or leave Johnny
Michaels podcast
we have a we have new footage
of the orange Mussolini Jesus
wandering around Mar-A-Lago trying to
find the evidence that he needs to the
lead every everybody
we wanted to have you on this Monday
don't forget as you leave hit that like
button hit the like and if you didn't
like the show [__] you go ahead and hit
the dislike button anyways okay if you
don't like the show fine whatever but
hit the dislike button for me would you
please would you do that and and leave a
nasty comment why not leave a name nasty
excuse me excuse me excuse me nasty
nasty
so leave leave a leave a comment hit the
dislike button or if you like the show
like the the comment if you love us or
you love to hate us go ahead and
subscribe to the YouTube channel either
way it's free it doesn't cost you
anything to hit that subscribe button
also it doesn't cost you anything to
watch it on Facebook at the Tony
Michaels you just follow us over there
at the Tony Michaels you can watch it
for free on on Twitch as well follow us
for free on Twitch twitch.tv slash meet
Tony Michaels also don't forget
we've had plenty of people today
resubscribe with their Amazon Prime
account that they have tied to their
Twitch account and if you want to tie
your Amazon Prime account to your Twitch
account just go to the Tony michaels.com
at see tonymichaels.com you'll find the
directions is the fourth one down on how
to give us a couple bucks each month
with your Prime account not costing you
a single extra dime when you link your
Amazon Prime account to your Twitch
account giving us that couple extra
dollars and if you already have it
linked go ahead and hit re-subscribe as
well download every single episode of
the Tony Michaels podcast in the
afternoon on Apple Spotify and Google
it's free 99 you get a five finger
discount on all the directories for the
audio version you should download it
helps the show also go check out
patreon.com I am Gabe Sanchez or what
was thatshow.com check out what Gabe's
doing on patreon while you're on patreon
don't forget to look at the round table
of democracy on my patreon page we're
doing killer things over there go to
patreon.com the Tony Michaels figure out
what find out what we're doing on
Roundtable democracy and there's a
playlist now if you go to YouTube and
you go to the playlist tab there's a
playlist for Roundtable democracy you
can watch the round tables of democracy
for free you do not have to join patreon
to consume the content but if you want
to join in live you want to get in the
chat you want to ask me or the guests a
few questions about the round table
about the workshop go to patreon.com the
Tony Michaels don't forget
oh boy going to be here tomorrow but
you're you're going to be out the rest
of the week right yeah so Wednesday
Thursday Friday okay
I know so so uh Gabe will join us
tomorrow with Texas Paul and then I will
be on my own Wednesday Thursday Friday I
think what I'll do is find someone who
wants to do bonehead of the week we're
gonna have a guest bonehead of the week
I'm gonna find somebody I don't know who
we'll get you know what you should do
you should go down in the comments after
the show and put who you want
it happens it happens yes I did miss the
poll someone's asking oh by the way I uh
I think Margie uh reminded me on Friday
so I finally made a pardon blanket
did you really yeah okay let's hear it I
got a couple of minutes hurry up go
ahead all right so you can go to my
store which is
store.imgapesanchez.com and you can look
up the part here I'll just pull it up
right now you can also you can also go
to the tonymichaels.com and you and Gabe
Sanchez is merch stores right there the
link to it you just click the just click
the Gabe Sanchez merch store so either
go to
store.imgavesanchez.com or go to
thetonymichaels.com Gabe Sanchez's store
is there are you giving me the link is
that what you're doing yeah I'm gonna
give you link right now oh well I mean I
could I could type it in I guess oh well
I'm gonna give you the [__] thing oh
here it is okay here here is the pardon
blanket if you guys everyone's been
wanting pardon blankets so if you want
to get a pardon blanket wrap yourself up
here is the keep yourself warm here is
the pardon blanket on Gabe Sanchez's
store you can go grab you a pardon
blanket now right now at 50 by 60
or a 60 by 80 depending on I mean if it
depends how how many crimes you're
trying to right yeah I mean you know
yeah you got to cover up if you guys if
you got crimes and you need pardoning
this blanket will do it for you yeah so
there you go there's this pitch
um so go to
store.imgapesanchez.com or again you go
to the Tony michaels.com his store link
is right there underneath the merch uh
heading so go get you a pardon blanket
so you're all if you want to keep you
warm and safe all warm and fuzzy for
tomorrow because we'll be here same time
same place
Surf's Up [__] you've been
listening to the Tony Michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events and political news no rules No
Boundaries I think we've made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow toning on social media
at the Tony Michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[__] em
[Music]
phys muleborn headass Beacon
all right
oh yeah